ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนค่ะหรือเอ
วันนี้วันอะไรคะ
เขียนไม่ได้ค่ะขอแชร์สกรีนนะคะ
พูดอะไรจะเขียนก็เขียนที่ไหนถ้าไม่ Share
screen
ผู้หญิงวันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะวัน
อังคาร
ใส่ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 14
14 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายนปีพตอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะมีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะแต่ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะพรุ่งนี้
เวลางาน
8:40  9 นาทีครับคือไอ้เขียนอะไร
08:49 นาทีค่ะเขียนก่อน
2 ทุ่มสี่สิบเก้านาทีกลางคืนร้านอื่นใช่
ค่ะปลาไม่ๆๆๆเพราะกลางวันเนี่ยเรานอนเยอะ
แล้วเราก็เลยตื่นมาสอนตอนกลางคืนค่ะโอเค
คุยลบนะคะนักเรียนได้ค่ะครูเอ๋ลบ
ๆ r-cooh หญิงวันนี้ครูเอ๋มีคำถามรู้โอเค
มีคำถามแล้ว
อุ้ยหายไปไหนโอเคคำถาม
ถามครูหญิง
ใช่ไหมคะถามผู้หญิงค่ะมั้ยถามนักเรียนให้
นักเรียนดูแล้วก็ฟังค่ะนะคะแฟนนักเรียน
ช่วยครูหญิงคิดได้
คำถามครูเอ๋เนี่ยอยู่ใน
ประเทศไทยเอา
ได้ค่ะพอดีพี่หญิงเป็นคนไทยต้องรู้จัก
ประเทศไทย
เอกขยายประเทศไทยก่อนนะคะค่ะอาคำถามของ
ครูเอ๋น่าจะเกี่ยวกับประเทศไทยเกี่ยวกับ
ตับเอ็มอี
ภาคเหนือค่ะ
ไอ้แหว่งเองคุยแบ่งเองถ้ากลางค่ะ
อะไรคะงานอีสาน
ภาคอะไรคะภาคตะวันออกและก็
ภาคอะไรคะทากตะวันตก
แล้วก็ภาคอะไรคะสุดท้ายภาคใต้โว้ย
เกี่ยวกับชาติต่างๆในประเทศไทยหรอคะให้
คุณหญิงเกี่ยวกับภาคต่างๆในประเทศไทยผู้
หญิงเก่งค่ะจริงเปล่าไม่กูเองๆกูเอกจะให้
ครูหญิงดูรู้
ไม่มีปิดอ่ะไม่มีปิดให้ดูเลยนะคะดูทั้ง
หมดดูหมดแล้วครูเอกก็บอกด้วยอ่าบอกด้วย
ว่าชื่ออะไร
โทรโขแล้วก็ให้ครูหญิงคิดว่าอยู่อะไรหรอ
คะ
ใครกินเด็กอยู่ภาคอะไร
2 อยู่จังหวัดอะไรอา
งองูมี Choice ไหมคะ ABC
จังหวัดได้นะไม่ต้องก็ได้นะไม่ต้องนะไม่
ต้องพอมีภาคแล้วจังหวัดจะคิดได้ให้ศาล
สั่งง่ายขึ้นเล่นแล้วถ้าครูเอ๋สู้ไหมสู้
ไม่บอกนะกูเองไม่บอกไม่มี ABC นะอ่าคิด
เองจังหวัดอะไรแม่ได้ๆถ้าครูหญิงถาม
จังหวัดหยุดมี type  A  B  C โดนฆ่า 10%
รถโหไม่เอาคุณต้องคิดเอง
โอเคค่ะ
ภาพแรกจากผู้หญิง
โอเคถามอะไรคะถามตึกหรือว่าถามถนนตึกค่ะ
ตึกๆๆๆๆ
[เพลง]
สีเหลืองไงคะเด็กสีเหลืองจริงยาวไปจะมูล
สีอื่นก็มีค่ะด้วยค่ะเนี่ยชื่อเอาชื่อนะ
คะชื่ออะไร
ที่โนโปรตุกีสที่ไม่เป็นภาษาไทยเลยนะคะ
ชิโนโปรตุกีส
ครูเอ๋อยากถามว่า
อะไรอีกแบบชิโนโปรตุกีสเนี่ย
อยู่ภาคอะไร
ในรูปใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋พรุ่งนี้รูปนี้รูปนี้
โอเคเอกช่วยไม่ใช่กรุงเทพฯ
ภาคใต้
บอกทำไมไม่ใช่กรุงเทพฯถ้ากูยังไม่บอกผู้
หญิงก็จะคิดกรุงเทพฯนะไม่คิดคู๋ผู้หญิง
รู้ว่าอยู่ที่ไหนเข้ากรุงเทพฯก็มีคล้ายๆ
กันกับไม่เหมือนกันอันนี้ไม่ไม่มีโรสต์
เอาอะไรมากผู้หญิงตอบภาคใต้นะคะภาคใต้หนู
ภาคใต้ใช่ไหมคะ
ต้องใช่ค่ะๆเองเก่งมาก
จังหวัดอะไร
คิดว่า
จังหวัด
จังหวัดอะไรข้างๆเอกกะใหญ่ทักไปให้
ผู้หญิงวงกลมเองมั้ยไม่คุยจะคุยจะทำให้
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าอยู่จังหวัด
จังหวัดอะไรอยู่ 7 ค่ะครูภูเก็ต
เก่งมาก
เอาไป 2 คะแนน
เย้
1  2
ผู้หญิงตอบช้าถูกตอบจังหวัดถุให้ 2 คะแนน
นะคะหาพี่
ภูเก็ตสวยมากนะครูเอ๋ชายสวยมากกล้วยเคยไป
ดูไหมคะไปดูกับไปดูจริงๆครูเอกเคยดูแต่
ว่าดูตอนที่ยังไม่ทาสีใหม่
ต้องดูแบบสี
9 เก่าอันนี้เขาทาสีใช่ไหมคะมีมีสีให้
โทษค่ะ
มีเอานี้ดีกว่าจะได้เห็นชัดมีกระป๋องสี
แล้วค่ะมีมีลูกกลิ้งใช่ไหมครับแบบนี้
รักจุงลงไปข้างในสีเหลืองๆแล้วก็ทานี้อา
ทานภาษีใหม่ยังไม่ได้ดูแต่ตอนไม่ทาสีแนะ
ครูเอ๋ดูนะคะเคยไหมชอบมีตอให้นี่แหละ
ต่อไป
หาผู้หญิงอันนี้บ้านเหรอคะพี่เอ๋ให้ค่ะ
บ้านนะคะอ่าบ้านไทยมีชื่อค่ะผู้หญิงชื่อ
อะไรคะบ้านหลังนี้เป็นหลังเดียวไม่ได้ไม่
รู้กี่หลังอาบ้านหลังเดียวบ้าน 1 หลังแต่
ว่าจะมีเรือน 1 เรือนชั่วค่ะ 1 เรือน 2
เรือนสามเรือนรวมกันเป็นหนึ่งหลัง 1 หลัง
3 เรือนราคา
จะ 3 หรือ 4 ไม่แน่ใจได้ 33 เรียน
ถามอะไรคะชื่อคุ้มขุนแผน
เงี้ยเฮ้ยเออ
รถเก๋ง
คุ้มขุนแผน
[เพลง]
มากกลางอ่าโอเคอยู่ข้างผู้หญิงกลางไหมคะ
กลางอยู่ภาคกลางนะคะภาคกลางใช่ไหมคะใช่
ค่ะ
สบายใจแล้วตอนแรกผู้หญิงคิดอยู่ภาคเหนือ
มีจำไม่ได้ว่าบ้านภาคกลางการสร้างเหนือ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่า
ตู้อะไร
จังหวัดอยู่จังหวัดอะไรให้ครูหญิงวงกลม
เองไหมคะได้ค่ะได้ค่ะได้ค่ะเดี๋ยวนะรู้
ว่าถูกมั้ยนะคะนักเรียนภาคกลางจังหวัด
เยอะมากอื้ม
ใหญ่ๆเลยคุยนะเนี่ยไม่เห็นหน้าเนาะครู
หญิงคิดว่าอยู่จังหวัดจังหวัดนี้แล้วกัน
จังหวัดสุพรรณบุรีค่ะค่ะอ่ะ
เปลี่ยนใจไหมคะ
ก็ไม่รู้
นะ
ไม่เปลี่ยนใจก็ได้เปลี่ยนใจค่ะไม่เปลี่ยน
ใจนะผิดเดี๋ยวครูเอกก็บอกว่าหยุดทุกขวด
อะไร
นักเรียนคุยน่ะเขาเรียนแล้วเขาก็จำชื่อ
ได้ว่าอกขุนแผนมิสเตอร์ขุนแผนเนี่ยพ่อแม่
เนี่ยอยู่สุพรรณบุรีไต้หวัน
มีมิสเตอร์ 1 คนนะคะชื่อขุนแผนคุณในห้อ
คุณแม่
สุพรรณบุรีใช่ไหมใช่นี้ก็เลยคิด
สุพรรณบุรีใส่ต่อไปก่อนเลยสุพรรณบุรี
เออจริงก็เป็นคนสุพรรณบุรีแต่เขาทำงาน
อยุธยา
ง่ายกว่านั้นที่จะไปเป็นเรื่องสุพรรณบุรี
จะนะเนี่ยเขาไม่อยู่สุพรรณบุรีเขาอยู่
อยุธยา
[เพลง]
ผิดแล้วนะกูเองผิดค่ะคู่หญิง
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะผู้หญิงได้ไป 1 คะแนนนะคะอัน
นี้
คุ้มขุนแผนอยู่จังหวัดอยุธยาอยุธยาอยุธยา
นะคะคุ้มคุณมากนะสวยสบายอยู่คะ
ไม่มีคนนักเรียนไปอยุธยาและไปแล้วก็ดูได้
เป็นบ้านไทยกูเอชอบมากร้องขึ้น
ขึ้นขึ้นไปดูได้ใช่ไหมคะขึ้นไปดูได้ค่ะ
สวยมากผู้หญิง
ถ้ากูไม่กลับไปกับเอ๋อ่ะ
โห
สถานที่อาทิบ้านใช่ไหมคะบ้านไหมคะบ้าน
บ้านบ้านหน้าบ้านชื่อเพื่อชื่ออะไรคะ R
บ้านเนี่ยไม่
จริงๆไม่ได้มีชื่อแต่ว่าเขาเขาเรียกส่งก็
เล็กเรือนกาแล
5 ตรงนี้กูหญิงก็ได้ว่ากาแลค่ะหาอาเป็น
เป็นเรียนไทยนะกาแลนะคะเออครูเอ๋เนี่ยบอก
ชื่อบอกก็ได้อยู่ที่
พิพิธภัณฑ์
เรือนไทยจุดๆ
ชื่อจังหวัดใช่ไหมคะ
มีที่นี่หมู่บ้าน
บ้านไผ่บ้านไผ่อ่าอันนี้เขาเรียกพี่
พิพิธภัณฑ์เรือนไทยแล้วก็จุดจุดต่อไปดูใน
พิพิธภัณฑ์ไปดูไปดูไปดูไปดูบ้านไทยมังกร
เมื่อก่อนนะคะผู้หญิงคิดว่าผู้หญิงด้วย
ว่าพรรคไหนการ์ดเหนืออุ้ยไอ้คิวดีมากก็
ครูเอ๋พูดกาแลงอ่ะพี่เคยเรียนหนังสือนะกู
เองสมองดีแต่ละงวดอะไร
ไปตอนนี้นะจังหวัดจังหวัดนี้นะคะจังหวัด
นี้มีภูเขาสูง
ๆ
มีภูเขาสูงสีกูเขาสู่
ที่สูงมากๆ
เชียงใหม่แล้วกันค่ะเชียงใหม่เลี้ยงใหม่
เก่งมาก
ครูเอ๋บอกว่ามีภูเขาภูเขาสูงแล้วครูหญิง
ผิดก็ไม่โอเคแล้วนั้นจะให้ผู้หญิงไปเรียน
ใหม่นะครับ
หมอแล้วชื่อพิพิธภัณฑ์อะไรคะครูเอ๋
พิพิธภัณฑ์อะไรนะเรือนไทยล้านนาหออยู่ที่
เชียงใหม่นะคะมีเชียงใหม่ที่ที่
หมอเชียงใหม่
ดูได้เนาะดูได้เรียนไปดูได้ไปดูได้ที่
เชียงใหม่นะคะค่ะจังหวัดเชียงใหม่ - เข้
และทะเลเห็นแล้วใจดีจริงๆคุยคนจะให้เห็น
แค่นี้นะให้เหรอที่คู่แต่ก็เหมือนอันนี้
ผู้หญิงก็รู้แล้วนะคะว่าอยู่ภาคไหน
แล้วก็รู้จังหวัดด้วยนะคะคุณเอ๋ปิ๊งภาค
ตะวันออกก็ได้
อาจเป็นบ้านเหมือนกันบ้านบ้านแบบนี้นะคะ
บ้านของคนเหรอเหนคนค่ะหนูบ้านคุณมีชื่อ
มั้ยเอ่ออันนี้
หมู่บ้านมอแกน
ไปเถอะผิดก็ไม่รู้หรอกจังหวัดอะไร
หมู่บ้านมอแกนนะคะหมู่บ้านมอแกนเป็นแบบ
นี้นะก็แบบนี้ผู้หญิงจะเห็นทะเลเนาะทะเล
ค่ะผู้หญิงเห็นทะเลด้วยทะเล
ไม่ใช่ภาคเหนือครูติ่งพระชัยกันอีสานไม่
ใช่มะทะเลนะไม่ใช่เหนือไม่ใช่อีสานกลาง
และมีทะเลตะวันออกก็มีทะเลตะวันตกก็มี
ทะเลภาคใต้ก็มีทะเลค่ะหมู่บ้านมอแกนอยู่
ข้างไหนคะหรือพากย์อะไรอยู่อยู่ภาคใต้ค่ะ
ภาคใต้อา
ก็ทะเลสวยถูกค่ะถ้าอยู่ภาคใต้
แล้วเอาหายไปไหนผู้หญิงแล้วภาคใต้เนี่ย
จังหวัดอะไร
จังหวัดอะไรอ่ะเออ
จังหวัด
ให้กูไอ้หินไหมคะ
กินก็ได้สอดครูเอ๋
จังหวัด
จังหวัดใกล้ๆภูเก็ต
ใกล้ที่สุดก็ไม่รู้ไม่ๆภูเก็ตก็มีใกล้
ภูเก็ตหลายๆจังหวัดนายเนี่ยพังยางอาญา
กระบี่ก็ใกล้ภูเก็ตแต่ครูหญิงคิดว่าพวกผี
ได้ยินคูเอพูดนะคะครูหญิง
จัน
พังงายาตะครูเอ๋ได้ยินกูเอกพูดเมื่อไหร่
ไม่ใช่ในคลังค่ะนักเรียนจังหวัดพังงาค่ะ
ครูเอ๋จังหวัดพังงา
แยกเก่งมาก
เก่งมากเก่งมากเก่งมากชมกันเองนะคะนะหลาน
ใช่ค่ะจังหวัดพังงาหมอหมู่บ้านมอแกนเกาะ
มอมอเกณฑ์หรอคะแล้วก็แทนค่ะเหมาะแก่ค่ะ
เหมาะแก่แล้วนักเรียนไปพังงาไปดูได้ใช่
ไหมคะคุณเอ๋ไปดูได้ไปดูได้เธอเปลี่ยนไปดู
ได้แค่นี้ค่ะอันนี้ได้ 2 ไงหรอแล้วก็อัน
นี้ไปออกตรงนี้เป็นเกาะผู้หญิงอ่ะนะคะ
มีเกราะราคา 5 เช่นชื่อเกาะหมู่เกาะ
สุรินทร์ก็จะมี
หมู่เกาะสุรินทร์นะคะจะมี 2 ต่อได้เกาะมา
แล้วก็เจ็บตรงนี้จะเป็นอ่าหมู่บ้านคน
xiaoli ราคาที่เหมาะแกนผู้หญิงได้ 2
คะแนนเย้
มีอีกไหมคะครูเอ๋ยังมีเวลาใช่ไหมคะมีห่า
มีเยอะเมียใช่ไหมมีประมาณ 10 กว่านาทีเลย
ค่ะกูอุ้ยคู๋ชอบไปนะที่เนี่ยไม่เป็นไรกู
เองนี่เยอะต่อไปไม่ใช่หมู่บ้านมิตรทะเล
อีกแล้ว
ที่นี่คุณเอกใจดีคู่หญิงคู๋นะฮะขอรูปหลาย
ๆรูปเลยมีรูปนึงไม่เอาไม่เป็นไรกูเองไม่
ต้องบอกชื่อก็ได้มีรูปนี้
รู้มีรูปนี้สวยไหมสวยๆในรูปนี้มีอะไรคะ
ครูหญิงอันนี้หน่อยคะมีนกเหรอคะพญาครุฑ
ครุฑ
หาหลักก็มีมีรูปปั้นน็อกไม่มีรู้ไม่ใช่
รูปปั้นเป็นไม้ไม้
ไม้ไม้ละเขาก็แกะค่ะเป็นพญาครุฑเป็นโรค
เป็นนางฟ้าเป็นเทวดาเป็นเทพนะถึงหน่วยมาก
ทั้งหมดเป็นไม้
หวานๆ
นะคะ
ครูเอ๋คะชื่ออะไร
อันนี้ทีชื่อ
[เพลง]
ที่จังหวัดชลบุรี
จังหวัดชลบุรีผู้หญิงสวยมันก็คือผู้หญิง
ชลบุรีค่ะชลบุรีภูฟ้าก็ชลบุรีมีใครไม่ออก
ตีสามคน
จังหวัดชลบุรีค่ะใช่ไหมครับครูเองใช่ค่ะ
คู่หญิงเก่งมากในผู้หญิงเก่งวันนี้ครูเอ๋
ปราสาทสัจธรรมครูหญิงเคยไปดูขอ
แผนที่กูเอ๋จะย่อแผนที่
หรือซื้อ
สักครู่นะคะแล้วกูย่อแผนที่ก่อนได้ค่ะโห
ภาษาศาสตร์จะพามาให้ดูอีกรอบนะคะสวยมาก
ค่ะพี่ขอเคลียร์ชลบุรีของผู้หญิงกันนะคะ
สวยเนาะ
สวยจังตาก็ใช่อ่ะสิคือว่าถ้านักเรียนไปดู
นักเรียนจะคิดครูโอ๋
สวยมากมายค่ะชื่อปราสาทสัจธรรมผู้หญิงเคย
ไปเลยไปค่ะเอกเคยดูไกลๆน้องผู้หญิงเคย
เข้าไปแล้วก็เดินข้างในเลย
ยังไม่เคยเดินเดินเดินเลยผู้หญิงไปทำไม
ไม่ชวนกูเอ๋ไปด้วยคุยไปญี่ปุ่นค่ะ
ทำไมกูอยู่ญี่ปุ่นผู้หญิงแหละ Happy  New
Year ไปมาใกล้ๆพัทยานะคะนครินทร์ใกล้ๆ
บ้านครูฟ้า
สาธุซ้ายนะค่ะนี่ไหมครับครูเอ๋มีนี่
สวย
สวยมากๆสีขาวค่ะอ่ะเธอชื่ออะไรเนี่ยอัน
นี้เป็นวัดหรือว่าเป็นบ้านครับครูเอ๋เป็น
วัฒนา
วัดชื่ออะไรคะวัดร่องขุ่นนี้ครูหญิงคะวัด
ร่องขุ่นอยู่
คาดอะไรคะ
อยู่ภาคเหนือค่ะพระ
ถูกต้องค่ะ
จังหวัดอะไรคะ
ไหนน้า
แต่ว่าไม่เป็นไรค่ะเพราะว่าเชียงใหม่ไป
แล้ว
กูเองไม่เอาเชียงใหม่ครั้งที่ 2 ใช่มั้ย
เชียงใหม่ครั้งที่ 2 ไม่ได้คิดว่าจังหวัด
เชียงรายค่ะเสียงราย
ถูกต้องค่ะ
เย้
เจียงราย
เชียงรายออกสัตว์มีการจดจะทำผู้หญิงได้ 2
คะแนนใช่ไหมคะใครค่ะ 2 คะแนนขุนแผนในราคา
ได้ 1 คะแนนแล้วก็วัดร่องขุ่นได้ 2 ท่าน
แอนเก่งมากกล้วยเคยไปดูไหมคะวัดร่องขุ่น
เคยครูเอ๋ยาไปค่ะอยากไปคิดว่า 1 วันจะ
ต้องไปนะวันนึงอ่ะเด็กวันหนึ่งวันนึงต้อง
มีต้องมีวันหนึ่งครูเอ๋ไปให้ได้ค่ะอ๋อผู้
หญิงกลับไปค่ะ
อะไรคะเนี่ยครูเอ๋รูปนี้ปราสาทหินค่ะ
โอโห้มันปราสาทสัจธรรมไม่ได้ไม่มีไม่
เหมือนป่ะอาจจะบางอย่างที่ปราสาทสัจธรรม
เหมือนปราสาทหินนะคะ
ปราสาทสัจธรรมเนี่ย
และก็จะดูที่ปราสาทหินแล้วก็เอาไปแล้วแกะ
แกะ
แต่ปราสาทหินเป็นหินใช่ไหมคะเป็นหินผู้
หญิง
ผู้หญิงรู้ชื่อไหมคะชื่ออะไรเนี่ย
ขนมรุ้ง
เก่งว่าหรือมองเห็นว่าแกไม่ใช่ดูนี่ไงนี่
ๆอยู่ตรงนี้อ๋อ
แราสาทหินพนมรุ้ง
ปราสาทหินพนมรุ้งอยู่ภาคไหนคะผู้หญิงภาค
อะไรภาคไหนภาคเหมือนกันชาติ
เหมือนมันออกภาคตะวันตกภาคใต้
ครั้งที่กูเองไม่ได้พูดค่ะภาคอีสาน
ปิงปอง
เพลงอยู่ภาคอีสานแล้ว
พี่อยู่จังหวัดอะไรคะนักเรียนผู้หญิงอยู่
จังหวัดอะไรค่ะครูเอ๋อยู่จังหวัด
บุรีรัมย์
เก่งจะรอยทำไมเล่นหูครูเอ๋ทุกคนรู้จักเรา
เรียนหนังสือออกก่อ
[เพลง]
โอ้นี่ค่ะคู่หญิงรูปนี้อะไรคะครูเอ๋เอ๋
วัดเหรอคะอ่าที่วัดแต่เขาเรียกว่าพระธาตุ
นี้ธีรทาส
พระธาตุพนม
อันนี้ใช่ไหมคะพูดเองถ้าใช่พระธาตุพนมนะ
คะ R พระธาตุพนมชายพระธาตุพนมเนี่ยครู
หญิงคะอยู่ขาดไหมคะ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่ายังไม่เอาผ้าให้กูหญิง
เลยไอ้พันธาตุพนมอยู่ภาคไหน
อยู่ภาคอีสาน
ภาคภาคอีสานมาอีสาน
โอเคอยู่ภาคอีสานถูกต้องค่ะคุณ
ป้าเก่งมากผู้หญิงชาเห็นสุดท้าย
ผู้หญิงจะตอบถูกมั้ยจังหวัดอะไรคะ
ครูหญิงคิดว่าจังหวัดนี้ค่ะขยายให้
พระธาตุพนมอยู่จังหวัดอะไร
ชื่อ
พระธาตุพนมก็อยู่จังหวัดนครพนมค่ะ
ชื่อเหมือนกันชื่อพระธาตุพนมไปอยู่
จังหวัดเชียงใหม่ไม่ได้ใช่ไหม
จังหวัดนครพนมค่ะครูเอ๋พระธาตุพนมก็อยู่
จังหวัดนครพนมมนะคะผมข้า
เอ้ยผู้หญิงก็ได้แผนขุนแผนได้ไป 2 คะแนน
เดี๋ยวถ้าเป็นอาญานักเรียนว่าผู้หญิงถ่าย
ที่ไหนถูกบ้างจังหวัดพระธาตุพนมอยู่ภาค
อีสาน
จังหวัดนครพนม
ค่ะได้ 2 คะแนน
ปราสาทหินพนมรุ้ง
อยู่ภาคอีสานนะคะอยู่ภาคอีสาน
นะคะภาคอีสาน
อะไรคะบุรีรัมย์นะครับพอดีรำกันนะเปลี่ยน
ดีกว่า
อันนี้ดีกว่าจังหวัดบุรีรัมย์นะคะอันนี้
สี่แล้วนะผู้หญิง
อ่ะอะวัดร่องขุ่นนะคะอยู่หากผ้าอะไรคะผู้
หญิงภาคเหนือจังหวัดอะไรคะจังหวัด
เชียงรายก็ 6 เอาคะแนนช่วยนับคะแนนนะคะ
แล้วก็
ปราสาทสัจธรรม
นะคะอยู่ภาคอะไรนะคะผู้หญิงโยภาคตะวันออก
ภาคตะวันออกจังหวัดอะไรคะ
จังหวัดชลบุรีก็ 8 คะแนน
ต่อไปค่ะอ่า
พิพิธภัณฑ์เรือนไทยร้านนานะคะร้านมอร์แกน
ก่อนไม่ใช่วัดประกันแล้ว
โอเคหมู่บ้านมอแกนอยู่ภาคอะไรคะอยู่พลาด
ใต้อยู่ภาคใต้นะคะจังหวัดอะไรคะ
จังหวัดพังงา
จ.พังงา
นะคะที่
พิพิธภัณฑ์เรือนไทยล้านนา
ที่อยู่ภาคอะไรคะ
เหนือค่า Mask เหนือจังหวัดอะไรคะ
จังหวัดเชียงใหม่ดอกจังหวัดเชียงใหม่นะคะ
ที่ต้องสอนคะแนนนี่เราเรียกว่าเรียนไทย
เรือนกาแลค่ะเรือนกาแลเป็นบ้านไทยมีกาแลน
นิ
สับไปคุ้มขุนแผน
เล็ก 1 คะแนนอยู่ภาคกลางอ่ายังไม่ได้ถาม
เลยอยู่ภาคอะไรคะอยู่ภาคกลางค่ะอยู่ภาค
กลางพัทยาบางภาคกลางจังหวัดอะไรคะ
จังหวัดอยุธยาจังหวัดอยุธยา
ก็ได้ 13 คะแนนว่าได้ 1 คะแนนอะไรกันเล่า
ต่อไปอันแรกเลย
ตึกเป็นนี้นะคะชิโนโปรตุกิสอยู่ภาคอะไรคะ
ถ้าใต้ค่ะ
ปลายจังหวัดอะไรคะ
ภูเก็ต
ภูเก็ตผู้หญิงก็ถูกเลขกับกี่คะแนนเนี่ย
สุด 5 คะแนนขอ 88 ที่ใช่ไหมไปค่ะผู้หญิง
ถูก 7 ครึ่งเออเพราะว่าเรือนคุ้มขุนแผน
เนี่ยผิดจังหวัดสมัยโจจังหวัดไม่ได้โกรธ
คิดแล้วนะอยุธยาหรือเปล่า
โอเคค่ะวันนี้ก็หมดเวลานะคะนักเรียนก็รู้
จักอะไรนะสถานที่เนาะเป็นบ้านเป็นปราสาท
เป็นวัดเป็นตึกสวยๆที่ไทยนะคะบายค่ะแล้ว
ก็พระธาตุด้วย
ขอให้พระธาตุด้วยถ้านักเรียนมาก็ไปดูได้
นะคะใส่ขึ้นนี้หมดเวลาเดี๋ยวเราเจอกัน
ใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ